[Applause]
guess what everyone we've got a really
fun surprise
because it's a celebration today that's
right everyone
in our audience is turning 40 this year
in 2020. so happy
40th year of life to you guys and in
fact
hmm we actually have someone in the wall
whose birthday it is
today so brie
are you there hi
bri happy birthday
[Applause]
yeah there you go
can you hear me bree i can
happy birthday thank you so much
2020 40 very like symmetrical numbers
in a crazy year right yes this is
the hardest year and hopefully we can
also make it one of the most
magnanimous years for and with each
other
this is so epic and brie um we actually
have a little surprise for you
which is okay we have some friends of
yours here on the wall
it's a surprise party that's right
do you see i'm so excited those are your
friends holding up
faces of you how fun
i love it brie what is your wish for
this year
oh that's such a hard one um i think
just kind of
you know getting back to normal
and being and seeing all of my friends
again
i really you know my husband was just
asking what i wanted for my birthday and
it's just been so hard because
i just wanted to be with my friends
right you're like on the birth
verse first you're bursting under tears
you're like it's 20
20. i'm turning 40. my friends are
holding up cardboard faces so this is as
good as it's gonna get
and that's at the same time hoping until
things start to normalize in our new
normal hopefully things will never be
the same we will grow
and learn and take all the lessons of
this year
and like i feel you bree
i really do so happy birthday
here's to it thank you so much
incredible year full of challenges hope
and like togetherness in every single
form we can get it
by the way bri did you know that you
share a birthday with kim kardashian
i love her so we're going to give a big
birthday shout out to none
other than kim kardashian today that's a
cool person to share it with
i love her look at her i mean she's
she's the coolest
40th year of life
and birthdays and this is such an
amazing year
40 2020 a beautiful rounded number
and there's an amazing company dylan's
candy bar the world's
largest confectionary emporium well
their lifestyle brand is helping our
audience
and sending some gift certificates for
you guys for your birthday
so eat some candy
celebrate i really wish you all the very
best for this year
i know this is a very difficult year but
hopefully you can take
all of this incredible energy harness it
make your wishes and dreams come true
realize them
and share them with other people because
that's what we're here for
is to take care of each other i'm
honored to celebrate this year with you
guys
i wanted to be the best year of your
life and everybody who's watching
just know here's my heart i give it to
you i hope you have a great day
carry this loving energy with you
[Music]